MESSAGE THIS MORNING FROM THE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT TO HIS
PEOPLE ON THE COLLECTIVE NUMBER
OF SURVIVAL.
>> WE'VE HARDLY SLEPT FOR SEVEN
NIGHTS.
ALL WE SLEEP BUT ANXIOUSLY.
MY DEARS, THE TIME WILL COME
WHEN WE WILL BE ABLE TO SLEEP
BUT IT WILL BE AFTER THE WAR, IN
A PEACEFUL COMPANY.
>> THAT NUMBER OF 2,000 KILLED
IS JUST CIVILIANS.
I WANT TO BRING IN CNN'S MATTHEW
CHANCE.
HE IS IN THE UKRAINIAN CAPITOL
AND WE DID JUST HEAR FROM
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY.
YOU ACTUALLY SPOKE TO THE
PRESIDENT IN HIS BUNKER.
>> Reporter: I DID, INDEED.
WE WERE MOVED TO -- ACTUALLY
INVITED TO AN UNDISCLOSED
LOCATION IN THE CENTER OF KYIV,
A SECRET LOCATION AND WERE TAKEN
TO A CAR AND DRIVEN SOMEWHERE
ELSE, STILL IN THE CENTER OF THE
CITY AND THEN WE WERE SORT OF
HERDED DOWN THROUGH THE SANDBAGS
AND MACHINE GUN POSTS INTO THE
BOWELS OF A HUGE BUILDING IN THE
CENTER OF KYIV AND THAT'S WHERE
EVENTUALLY PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
ARRIVED.
HE MENTIONED THERE HE HADN'T
SLEPT FOR SEVEN DAYS AND LIKE
MANY OTHER UKRAINIANS, FEELS THE
SAME FEELING, A LOT OF STRESS.
WHEN HE APPEARED HE WAS IN GOOD
SPIRITS.
BUT HE DID LOOK LIKE HOOE WAS
TIRED.
HIS EYES WERE BLOOD SHOT,
WEARING THE MILITARISTIC
UNIFORM.
I SPOKE TO HIM ABOUT THE REFUSAL
OF THE UNITED STATES AND OTHER
NATO COUNTRIES TO IMPOSE A
NO-FLY ZONE.
TALK A LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAID
ABOUT THAT -- WHAT I SAID ABOUT
THAT AND WHAT HIS ANSWER WAS.
>> THE UNITED STATES HAS SAID
THAT IT WILL NOT ENFORCE A
NO-FLY ZONE OVER THIS COUNTRY.
AND IT WON'T PUT BOOTS ON THE
GROUND.
DO YOU THINK IT IS NOW TIME FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND OTHER
WESTERN COUNTRIES TO RECONSIDER
THAT AND TO HELP YOU, NOT JUST
WITH MILITARY AID BUT WITH
MANPOWER?
>> Translator: I'VE ALREADY TURN
TO SOME FOREIGN LEADERS WITH
THIS REQUEST.
I BELIEVE THAT LEADERS MUST
SUPPORT DEMOCRATIC STATES OF THE
WORLD WHO ARE KEEN TO DEFEND
COUNTRIES.
THE POWERFUL ISSUE OF CLOSING
THE AIRSPACE HELPS US
TREMENDOUSLY.
THIS DOES NOT MEAN DRAGGING NATO
INTO THIS WAR.
WE SPOKE MANY TIMES WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND I'M THANKFUL
FOR THESE OPPORTUNITIES AND FOR
SUPPORT.
BUT THEY DID NOT HEAR ME.
I'VE BEEN TELLING THEM THAT
UKRAINIAN WILL FIGHT HARDEST BUT
US ALONE AGAINST RUSSIA, WE WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO DO IT.
>> Reporter: AT THE MOMENT,
THERE WERE BIG EXPLOSIONS
YESTERDAY IN WHICH FIVE PEOPLE
WERE KILLED.
BUT IT'S VERY, VERY QUIET AT THE
MOMENT, EVEN THOUGH WE ALL KNOW
ON THE OUTSKIRTS OF THIS CITY
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF RUSSIAN
TROOPS, A HUGE COLUMN OF RUSSIAN
ARMOR MAKING IETS WAY TO THE
OUTSKIRTS ON MANY ASSUME WILL BE
A BIG ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL.
A SECOND ROUND IS COMING TODAY
ACCORDING TO OFFICIALS.
THERE IS THAT SWORD, THAT HAMMER
HANGING OVER THE AREA WHEN IT
COMES TO THAT POTENTIAL USE.
>> THAT NUMBER WE WERE GIVEN TO
THE STATE EMERGENCY SERVICES OF
2,000 CIVILIANS KILLED NOW IN
UKRAINE, I SUPPOSE THAT'S NOT
SURPRISING GIVEN THE SCOPE AND
THE INTENSITY OF THE RUSSIAN
ATTACKS BUT YOU CAN SEE THE
PRICE THAT UKRAINIAN PEOPLE ARE
PAYING.
>> Reporter: YEAH, UNFORTUNATELY
THAT'S TRUE.
WHEN YOU HAVE, YOU KNOW, HEAVY
WEAPONRY SORT OF BATTLING IN
CIVILIAN
CIVILIAN POPULATION CENTERS, WE
SAW THE PICTURES OF BUILDINGS
BEING HIT, WHETHER INTENTIONALLY
OR NOT BY THE RUSSIANS, THERE'S
INEVITABLY GOING TO BE THAT KIND
OF DAMAGE TO CIVILIAN LIFE.
AND THE REAL PROBLEM IS, THE
EVEN BIGGER PROBLEM, IS THAT AS
THIS BATTLE INTENSIFIES AND IF
THE RUSSIANS DO STEP UP THEIR
TACTICS AND USE MUCH MORE FORCE
THAN THEY HAVE DONE SO FAR,
THOSE NUMBERS COULD SKYROCKET.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT VERY HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS OF CIVILIANS THAT
ARE IN THE LINE OF FIRE, IN
FRONT OF A MASSIVE RUSSIAN
ARMORED FORCE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S WHETHER WE THINK
IS RUSSIA CAPABLE OF, YOU KNOW,
FLATTENING CIVILIAN AREAS LIKE
THIS ONE?
I THINK MANY PEOPLE FEEL AND THE
RECORD SHOWS IN THE PAST THEY'VE
DONE THAT.
>> I THINK THE ANSWER IS YES.
MATTHEW CHANCE, THANK YOU FOR
THE WORK THAT YOU AND YOUR TEAM
ARE DOING.
>>> AND JOINING US IS RETIRED
MAJOR GENERAL MICHAEL REPASS,
COMMANDED COMMAND EUROPE AND IS
NOW A GLOBAL MEMBER IS HE
SPECIAL OPERATIONS FOUNDATION.
HE'S BEEN DIRECTLY INVOLVED WITH
UKRAINE SECURITY MATTERS SINCE
2016.
SIR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
WITH US.
THERE ARE OF COURSE AMERICANS
WHO HAVE TRAINED UKRAINIANS.
YOU'VE BEEN A BIG PART OF THAT.
I THINK PEOPLE WATCHING HAVE
BEEN SURPRISED BY THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE UKRAINIAN
MILITARY.
I WONDER IF YOU ARE.
>> NO, I'M NOT SURPRISED AT ALL.
THIS IS THE MANIFESTATION OF NOT
ONLY THE U.S.'S WORK BUT NATO'S
WORK SINCE 2014, 2015 TIME FRAME
WHEN WE PROVIDED EXTENSIVE
ADVISORY SUPPORT TO THE
UKRAINIAN ARMED FORCES.
BUT I WOULD ALSO SAY THERE'S
SOME INTERNAL DYNAMICS IN
UKRAINE THAT HAVE REALLY
CONTRIBUTED TO THE DEFENSES THAT
WE SEE SO FAR.
FIRST OFF THEY'RE SUPERBLY LED
BY COMBAT EXPERIENCED OFFICERS.
THE SECOND THING IS THEY'VE
PREPARED FOR THIS SCENARIO THAT
THEY FIND THEMSELVES IN.
THEY'VE PASSED LAWS, DONE A LOT
OF WORK INTERNALLY TO ORGANIZE
AND REFORM.
THEIR EDUCATION AND TRAINING
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN REFORMED WITH
HELP OF ADVISERS FROM THE U.S.
AND NATO.
THE TRAINING ASSISTANCE PROVIDED
BY THE WESTERN POWERS AND
WESTERN NATIONS HAS BEEN
EXCELLENT AND THEY'RE VERY WELL
TRAINED AT THE TACTICAL LEVEL,
BUT I THINK WHAT SURPRISED
PEOPLE THE MOST IS THE
RESILIENCE OF THE PEOPLE OF
UKRAINE.
THAT, TOO, IS NOT BY MISTAKE.
BEGINNING LAST YEAR WITH THE
NATO'S COMPREHENSIVE DEFENSE
HANDBOOK THAT WAS PUBLISHED,
UKRAINE WORKED ON THEIR
RESILIENCE INTERNAL TO THEIR
SOCIETY.
THEY'VE ACTUALLY PREPARED THEIR
POPULATION FOR THIS DAY WHEN IT
MIGHT COME.
THEY PASSED A LAW BACK IN JULY
ON RESILIENCE AND RESISTANCE AND
NATIONAL DEFENSE AND
SPECIFICALLY AUTHORIZED THE
STANDUP OF THE TERRITORIAL ARMY.
ALONG WITH THAT TALKED ABOUT
STRUCTURE FOR THE RESISTANCE.
>> AND WEF 'VE SEEN THESE
TERRITORIAL FORCES TAKING SHAPE
BEFORE OUR EYES.
WHAT CAN THEY DO AND CAN THEY DO
ANYTHING ABOUT, ONE, THIS
RUSSIAN CONVOY AND, TWO, THIS
INCREASING APPETITE ON THE PART
OF VLADIMIR PUTIN TO BE
INDISCRIMINATE WHEN IT COMES TO
CIVILIANS AND USING HEAVY
WEAPONS ON THEM?
>> GREAT QUESTIONS.
FIRST OF ALL, ON THE TERRITORIAL
ARMY, IT WAS A CADRE
ORGANIZATION THAT WAS AUTHORIZED
BY THE GOVERNMENT TO ROLL IN THE
MILITIAS, TO PROVIDE SOME
STRUCTURE AND LEGAL BASIS FOR
CIVILIANS TAKING UP ARMS AGAINST
EITHER A FOREIGN NATION OR EVEN
SOME OF THEIR OWN CITIZENS THAT
ARE COLLABORATORS, SO TO SPEAK.
SO THE LEGAL BASIS HAS BEEN
PROVIDED THERE.
THE TRAINING HAS NOT BEEN THAT
OF INFANTRY COMBAT TROOPS OR
EVEN AT THE POLICE LEVEL.
THESE ARE STRICTLY VOLUNTEERS
THAT GO OUT THERE.
IN REGARDS TO THAT CONVOY, HAVE
I HAVE TO LEAVE IT TO THE
TACTICAL EXPERTISE.
THEY KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON, THEY
KNOW WHAT TO DO.
IF THEY HAVE TO DO IT WITH THE
SPECIAL FORCES OR EVEN THE
TERRITORIALS.
THEY HAVE THE WILL, THEY WILL
FIGHT TO THE LEFT BULLET, THE
LAST RIFLE, THE LAST MAN.
>> CAN THEY STAND A SUSTAINED
ATTACK ON KYIV?
>> WHAT WE SEE IS THAT
TACTICALLY THE RUSSIANS ARE
STALLED.
THEY REALIZED THAT THEY'RE
TAKING EXTREME CASUALTIES.
AS A RESULT THEY'RE BACKING OFF
AND NOW DEPLOYING THEIR HIGHLY
DESTRUCTIVE CAPABILITIES,
DECISION WEAPONS, THERMOWEAPONS,
CLUSTER BOMBINGS AND MUNITIONS.
NOW THEY'RE GOING TO EMBARK ON A
CAMPAIGN OF IMMENSE DESTRUCTION,
FIRST OF, INFRASTRUCTURE,
COMMAND AND CONTROL IN ALL
ELEMENTS OF SOCIETY.
THEY'VE ATTACKED MUSEUMS.
THEY'RE GOING AFTER THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THE GOVERNMENT
CAN'T TALK TO THE PEOPLE AND
KEEP A COHERENT DEFENSE GOING.
SO WE HAVE TO ENABLE THEM
THROUGH DIRECT FOREIGN
ASSISTANCE OF AID, MILITARY AID,
TO BE ABLE TO GO OUT AND DESTROY
THE THINGS THAT ARE DESTROYING
THEM.
SO WE'RE IN A VERY CRITICAL TIME
NOW AND THE WINDOW IS CLOSING TO
DO ANYTHING THAT IS EASY OR
SIMPLE.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY CLOSED.
EVERYTHING FROM HERE ON OUT IS
GOING TO BE HARD.
>> IT'S EVEN HARD TO HEAR YOU
SAY THAT.
THAT'S CERTAINLY HOW IT FEELS AS
WE ARE WATCHING ALL OF THIS GO
ON AND DEVELOP